[Musica]
Io sono un istrione cantava Aznavour in
una canzone vecchia ma bellissima
ne so qualcosa delle maschere naso
qualcosa degli istrioni
sono agitatissimo e quindi dirò può
essere che io dica delle cose un pochino
frizzantine oggi e chiedo
preventivamente Scusa i signori boss del
text Sono Romina e sono una rotta in
cuore
mi sono sentita strana per tutta la vita
che dici Ma che parola dice figlia mia
già cominci così perché la parola strana
l'aggettivo strana Non fa avvicinare
nessuno
prima di salire tremava l'idea di
pronunciarla no Poi mi sono detta spero
che qualcuno là fuori o qui dentro possa
capire quanto sto per dire
sono stata una bambina strana capace di
grandi isolamenti e silenzi del mio
abisso e poi di parlantine teatrali non
conoscevo via di mezzo ma un bambino a
tutti i diritti di essere incoerenti
Voglio parlarvi del mio rapporto con lo
specchio perché secondo me non è solo un
oggetto che riflette l'immagine che ha
davanti
la prima lezione che ho ricevuto dallo
specchio che l'abito fa il monaco Ecco
perché ci tengo tanto a di solito
vestirmi in maniera superfluo perché per
tutta la vita ho combattuto con la
dentro di me avevo paura di mostrare la
mia tristezza
la mia tristezza era tipo lettera
scarlatta Ma che dico lettera scarlatta
lettera Patacca indelebile come il sugo
la tristezza non si deve mai far vedere
mai non lo so perché
e quindi nessuno tramite almeno i miei
accessori i miei vestiti devono pensare
che io possa essere una persona triste o
possa essere stata una bambina triste
vengo da una famiglia caotica non siamo
stati fortunati Però mi piace dire che
ce l'abbiamo messa tutta tutti quanti
Io da piccola doveva assistere con
impotenza dei grandissimi sbalzi di
umore
e dicono che un bambino possa vivere
come normale qualcosa che è normale non
è ma non è vero un bambino Omega è scemo
un bambino non è una copia Carbone un
bambino è una spugna al massimo un
bambino è uno specchio Io ero quella
bambina che si ritrovava davanti dalla
calma piatta la marcia su Roma con una
velocità che manco la Formula 1 e
sentivo il dovere perché nessuno me
l'aveva chiesto di scongiurare quei
momenti e diventava una pagliaccia e da
lì ho messo le prime maschere e quindi
mi inventavo un balletto
strambo oppure dicevo l'ultima battuta
che aveva fatto ridere alla volta alle
volte ci riuscivo a scongiurare quel
momento alle volte no
e poi devo aver pensato che proprio la
tristezza era un'onta una cosa orribile
Io ero un pagliaccio esperti
intrappolato nel corpo di una bambina
lo specchio però può rivelarti anche
come ti vedono gli amici vicini e
lontani C'è questo ragazzo che è
cresciuto nel mio stesso quartiere mio
coetaneo ultimamente siamo molto uniti e
tempo fa mi fa a Roma Ma perché non
giocavi mai con noi e io Istintivamente
ho risposto qualcosa come Ma perché io
non mi dovevo far sgamare
e mi fa e che stavi sotto copertura a 7
anni e sì perché avevo un ruolo da
mantenere io mi sentivo una femmina
vecchia pure a 7 anni e io odiavo la
leggerezza dei bambini Pensa una
ragazzina che si vergogna ad essere una
ragazzina Poi dici che in Toscana e
li odiavo loro con loro gioco a
nascondino il loro problema magari era
capire chi aveva barato e io dicevo non
sarò mai dei vostri Siete dei
figlioletti di buttare va bene
avete capito E già mi sono fatta
riconoscere al minuto 4 del Tex signori
lo sapevo già Ma insomma io penso questa
cosa che quando Dio distribuiva la
leggerezza e l'innocenza io devo essere
stata in fila per il poligono perché se
loro me lo spiego
era un elefantista intrappolata nel
corpo di una creatura
lo specchio un pochino ti spoilera che
volentano volente dico anzi ti conviene
volerlo Dovrei cominciare ad amare
l'immagine che hai di fronte
Allora ho studiato tanto e poi mi sono
potuta permettere la terapia mi sono
fatta vedere da uno bravo e ho scoperto
delle tanti problemi perché signori
avremo uno solo che sono istrionica che
parlando in pane e salamella diciamo sei
istrionico quando sai mettere le
maschere meglio degli altri e quando
pensi che solo mettendo la maschera le
persone ti vogliono bene perché la tua
vera essenza non va bene sei convinto di
questa cosa ci tieni tanto a sedurre
l'altro Ma no sedurre in senso suino eh
necessariamente Cioè tu nella tua testa
Succede questo che o fai divertire tanto
una persona o morte e danno programmato
male l'amore in un certo senso e quindi
L'amore non è per te non è per quelli
come te e te lo Dovrai sudare ti dovrei
sbattere come nome letto per ricevere
l'amore e poi la vita che fate dice sei
istrionica a me Romina Per esempio ha
detto così ha detto io come optional
telegalo te regalo pure una bella
sindrome dell'impostore che è quando
tutti senti meritevole quando hai paura
che l'altra persona ti sgami anche se
non hai fatto nulla di male non ti senti
mai meritevole
e tu mi dirai L'amore è una cosa Qui
abbiamo tutti e mi dirai Ma perché
all'amore o Anna in miniera per me è
stato per molto tempo la stessa cosa era
un sacrificio a soci l'amore al
sacrificio e quando c'è la sindrome
dell'impostore tutte queste cose vai
alla ricerca proprio dello straggle
perché quello è un codice familiare
diventi in un certo senso Lasciatemi
dire una calamita de miserabili Ma
perché un po ci ho pensato perché
secondo me dentro di te sai che cosa
pensi Pensi Magari alle volte può
succedere che scegli persone anche più
difficili di te da maneggiare in un
certo senso Perché pensi magari che non
sei solo tu il buco nero della coppia
oppure semplicemente perché ripeto
quello è un codice familiare e mi sono
sentita per tanto tempo un mendicante
intrappolato nel corpo di un innamorata
lo specchio però può rappresentare anche
un cambiamento che dovrai essere pronto
a vedere
ora a me piace dire una cosa che la vita
è un po'
Io rivendico tanto questa parola non
parlo di un mignottone da controviale io
dico proprio mignottina che secondo me
quella cosa che punta al sodo ma ogni
tanto ti fa i prezzi buoni e sì perché
cioè la sindrome dell'impossi perché
almeno la signora una gioia ci abbiamo
la sindrome dell'impostore è la cosa
buona che c'ha è che se una cosa non è
invalidante almeno diventa la tua
benzina e chi c'ha la sindrome
dell'impostore non si darà mai le pacche
sulle spalle e cercherà sempre di
migliorare Almeno questo Insomma Perché
il senso della vita secondo me imparare
e
Chiunque faccia terapia sa benissimo che
ogni tanto bisogna andare a
riacchiappare il bambino che è dentro di
noi che siamo stati perché ancora è lì
io ho trovato la ho ritrovato e
riacchiappato la bambina dentro me e
stare carcere minorile
alle volte ancora ride da matti e vuole
morire e non lo sa se fa bene a fare la
pagliaccia oppure no ma è così gli viene
naturale dicono che quello che non ti
uccide ti rende forti signori Non è vero
quello che non ti uccidete fa un culo
così alla francese ve lo dico però che
succede che a un certo punto decidi di
lavorare su di te e c'è una speranza
perché tu devi strappare il copione
della tua vita che ti vuole sempre lì a
mendicare a dare per scontato che la
difficoltà deve far parte della tua vita
e ricordo l'amore della mia vita la
prima volta che l'ho incontrato perché
Ricordatevi sta cosa che i rotti in
cuore di solito amano gli altri rotti in
cuore e non si fidano di quelli che
puzzano d'amore puzzano puzzano Avete
presente quelli che nel momento giusto
sono stati Amati danno l'amore per
scontato che volgarità
Insomma io faccio Sto appuntamento con
questa persona stupenda armoniosa
educata gentile Buona aveva voglia di
scoprirmi Io ho fatto le solite domande
che faccio io al primo appuntamento tipo
ma tu hai avuto crisi abbandoni che da
piccolo e lui ha risposto come qualcosa
cioè no io no possibile non ha avuto
paura che ti portassero via l'assistente
sociale No Chi io Ma che scherzi Sono
tornato a casa quel giorno e la mia
coinquilina mi aspettavo mi faceva è
questo che problemi C'ha mi faceva la
mia coinquilina che sapeva che io e io
ho risposto Serena te lo giuro È
talmente bella questa questo primo
appuntamento questo qua è armonioso
secondo me è un signore della droga
insomma in questi casi qua può strappare
il copione della tua vita ma sai come ti
senti Ti senti una donna intrappolata
nel corpo di una donna solo più sfigata
e che deve ricominciare tutto da capo
lo specchio
ti può dire sibillinamente che dovrà
essere pronta a indossare delle facce
ora c'è una cosa positiva quando metti
le maschere le metti in base a chi è
davanti in teoria è perché sai leggere
le persone e dici ma sarà un bel
superpotere questo
Il problema è che io ho imparato
prestissimo per evitare i piatti rotti a
leggere le micro espressioni facciali e
quindi un conto è leggere una persona
perché vuoi entrare nel suo mondo è un
conto è leggere una persona perché parti
già con le mani avanti che devi
difenderti da chissà quale sciagura
succederà
e quindi a forza di mettere maschere
Quelli come me arriva un giorno che si
chiedono Ma io che sono veramente se io
le levo Ste maschere Ma qualcuno saprà
amare la mia tetraggine ma qualcuno
saprà rispettarmi lo stesso verrò
abbandonata ancora oppure dici che c'ho
là sotto una specie di ritratto di
Dorian Gray umano se la levo e allora ti
senti un mostro con un superpotere di
merda intrappolato nel corpo di un
essere umano
però lo specchio ti può anche rivelare
anzi ti fa la domanda e ti dice chi
sarai ora L'istrione mette in scena la
sua vita e io come al solito Cliché
nella vita faccio la cantautrice solo
negli ultimi anni ho imparato però
levarla la maschera ho trovato la mia
isola felice perché io quando canto e
quando scrivo almeno per quei tre minuti
riesco a togliere la maschera e ho
deciso di scrivere solo di ombre perché
la felicità non la so descrivere e
soprattutto mi piace l'idea di
ritornare da quella bambina Pagliaccia o
dare simbolicamente una carezza a tutti
i rotti in cuore come me o quelli che
devono ricominciare tutto da capo e mi
piace farlo in contrasto perché io adoro
il contrasto quando dicono che in questa
società tutti quanti mettiamo maschere
certo nessuno vuole far vedere la crisi
esistenziale sui social o mentre va
Butta la monnezza io me ne rendo conto
ma è tutta la vita che sto lavorando per
levarmele le maschere e vedo che sta
imparando a mettere dico ma no ti stai
rovinando la vita e ci tengo tantissimo
a mostrarmi sempre come una specie di
Barbie cantante ripulita anche se dentro
sono così ombrosa così crepata ma è
proprio quella Quella è la mia armatura
non me l'ha levate mai anzi faccio
Seleziona la porta così perché Basta
vedere Ecco questo aspetto di fuori No
questo questa armatura e diventare che
io sia frivola ma va bene così e sono
una cantautrice di nicchia la cosa bella
è che nessuno dice mai però la voglio
rivendicare e che quando tu fai parte di
una nicchia Non è che bombardi tutti i
giorni le persone con in tv le persone
che ti scelgono ti hanno scelto
veramente
e per quello che sei e quindi più vai
avanti e più in quei tre minuti che
canti e che scrivi la canzone ti
dimentichi di nasconderti e di metterti
la maschera e
Anche se non so che cosa sarà di me però
mi piace però descrivermi nonostante il
contrasto e dire Vabbè mi sento un
muratore intrappolato nel corpo di un
vampiro
ora forse forse mi chiedo spesso ma
sbaglio io che mi sento sempre sbagliata
o sbagliano le persone che ci tengono
sempre tutti i giorni a mostrarsi come
moralmente superiori quelli che ti
devono insegnare la vita quelli che si
devono sentire sempre meglio e che ti
devono ribadire che stai sbagliando
Forse forse quelle maschere sono io cioè
sono parte di me forse forse le persone
a volte rappresentano Degli Specchi ma a
volte ci stanno Degli Specchi orrendi in
giro nel mondo ogni tanto ritorno da
quella bambina Pagliaccia e le dico che
alla fine doveva andare così e non
poteva portare maschera migliore e per
una volta una santa volta la stranezza
Forse è la cosa più vera che ciò
e adesso se con il vostro permesso
vorrei levarmi la maschera per un minuto
e mezzo e vi ringrazio con tutto il
cuore Grazie
E io ci credo in Dio ma lui forse non mi
crederà
[Musica]
e dove sta scritto che un prigioniero
non abbia pretese
Io voglio la luna e anche un cerotto per
le mie crepes
Ma io che ne so cosa sogna un artista Io
piango le mie melodie Ma poi e tu vuoi
seguirmi per mano tu sembri la luna il
lupo mannaro
[Musica]
tutti ci vogliono
anche
[Musica]
tu mentre tu
il nostro il buio che porto nel petto
rovino
[Musica]
tutto chi
sopravvivere
[Applauso]
[Musica]